dans quelques instants vous allez voir
des images qui ont été prises lors de la
réparation effectuée sur l'émetteur ont
donc d'alice il s'agissait être au fond
d'une réparation d'importance
relativement limitée apparemment puisque
il s'agissait seulement de réparer un
isolateur qui avait été fait les et qui
se trouvait un point de jonction de deux
parties de haut quand elles ont été
amenées à réduire la puissance de
l'émetteur pendant quelques quelques
semaines à sa moitié de sa valeur
maintenant la puissance est revenu
normal
et d'ailleurs nous nous préparons aussi
à augmenter la puissance de l'émetteur à
ondes longues de la nuit ce à partir de
l'année prochaine pour augmenter encore
le confort d'écouté pour se les
auditeurs qui prennent les émissions de
france inter sur cet émetteur et ils
sont nombreux et nous le savons mais en
fait les metteurs en nombre d' alice de
par ses caractéristiques et en puissance
sa situation géographique la
caractéristique que sa longueur d'onde
est une importance privilégié sur
l'ensemble du réseau français les
émetteurs il est un émetteur parmi
j'allais dire tant d'autres c'est à dire
parmi 200 d'émetteurs de radiodiffusion
qui couvre le territoire tant en ondes
moyennes en ondes longues ou en ondes
métriques s'est allié en modulation de
fréquence mais l'émetteur aung d'alise à
une place tél
dans la gamme des ondes permet une telle
continuité de réception notamment par
les automobilistes et que effectivement
nous lui avons apporté par le passé déjà
et à l'avenir bientôt tous nos souhaits
et si l ouïe souhaite installer l'unique
émetteur à ondes longues du réseau il
est constitué par un aérien de 310
mètres de haut qui est représentée ici
sur le schéma par ce mal qui est
maintenu et ancrés au sol par 15 au banc
dans la distribution en plan est donnée
par ce petit schéma
un probant sur chaque branche des toiles
disposé à 120° ses haubans maintiennent
le pylône en équilibre et chacun d'eux
étant dû à une tension de 20 tonnes ce
schéma représente l'un des côtés l'une
l'une des ligues de haubans et
représente sur chaque ligne
les cinq au ban de maintien nuage le
pylône est à la fois support d'antenne
et fait partie intégrante de l'antenne
c'est à dire qu'ils entrent dans le
dispositif de rayonnement de l'antenne
au mois de janvier dernier alors que
notre trafic était de 500 kilowatts
suivant les normes d'exploitation et les
possibilités de l'émetteur nous sommes
aperçu d'un incident grave à savoir un
amarrage permanent sur l'un des
isolateurs qui coupe les différents au
ban de maintien qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un amorçage nationales telles
annonces âge c'est un arc électrique qui
est permanent ou non celui ci était
grave parce que précisément ils étaient
permanents qui amorce entre deux masses
voisine au sort de court circuit ce tas
court circuit électrique
donc vous avez été obligé de mettre sur
chaque année au point une série 10 à la
terre je voulais dessiner sous la soirée
emplacement d'accord proximité dont un
bien sûr en pet qui disposé 6-1 à
l'ancrage disposées ici puis deux
intermédiaires
aussi approximativement leur disposition
et ceci sur chacun des haubans sur
chacun des enfants via son effet s'est
mise à la terre là qui est tombé en
panne
c'est celui là mais celui ci où nous
avons constaté désamorçage permanent
lorsque l'émetteur est en fonctionnement
alors donc pris ce connaisseur de
détérioration de l'isolateur lui même et
aussi mettant en cause la solidité de
l'édifice et risquent tout équilibre de
l'édifice tient que par goût des
premières mesures de sauvegarde a été de
baisser la puissance à 250 km au lieu de
500 que le régime normal
ensuite nous avons essayé rapidement de
court circuiter directeur en cause de
façon à ne pas augmenter la
détérioration et préserver l' ouvrage il
est entendu que ces dispositifs qui
était pris il n'était pas un titre
définitif et qu'il fallait penser les
solutions pour remettre en état le
la chape d'isolateurs qui avait lâché
donc il a fallu construire un outillage
spéciales et en particulier une nacelle
qui devrait s'adapter aux difficultés
de cette montée le long du haut quand
vous verrez c'est 100 à l'heure et vous
verrez le dispositif qui a été adoptée
dispositif de bascule pour pouvoir
franchir le premier la terre en question
alors cette nacelle avec une grue au sol
a été posée à cheval sur le hauban
souvent première difficulté c'est la
présence d'une bande dessous il n'était
pas possible de relâcher pour la
solidité de l'ouvragé
mais il a fallu que cette nacelle en
jambes soient prises de paroles dessus
et enjambe le hauban sans pouvoir s'en
portait sur l'auvent inférieur c'était
la première difficulté de mise en place
dans cette mise en place là avec expect
ces jours derniers et à partir d'une
poulie de renvoi placé au sommet du
pylône
cette nacelle été tirée par un câble il
descendait le long du fus du pylône est
renvoyé par une autre poule il renvoie
au sol sur un peu électriques
le problème qui se posait en effet
tantôt personnel qu'au matériel était
d'accéder à ce troisième isolateurs en
faisant franchir à la benne de
réparation les deux premiers iso la
terre entre la base et le sommet de la
tour un mécanisme à la fois très simple
et très délicat peut imaginer faisant
supporter la benne de travail par quatre
pouliches porteuses dont trois étaient à
tour de rôle toujours en contact avec le
câble due au vent mais dans la 4e
poulies porteuse selon la nécessité
pouvait être dégagée du câble porteur
permettant ainsi le passage de la benne
au dessus des obstacles que constituent
et cio la terre
au cas où le fil téléphonique venait à
couper faut absolument qu'on le sache
pourquoi conséquent bavarder
continuellement attention l'impératif
est essentielle pour les services
techniques étaient en effet de réduire
au minimum le temps d'interruption des
émissions pendant la réparation le
résultat de leur effort tient en un
chiffre commencé à 7 heures du matin la
réparation était terminé à quatre heures
du soir soit en tout 9 heures pour
accéder à l'isolateur à 250 mètres
d'altitude changer les pièces
défectueuses et redescendre ce tour de
force ne fut possible qu'en utilisant un
matériel spécialement conçu pour cette
opération tout en répondant aux normes
de sécurité aient manipulé par un
personnel hautement spécialisés
m
electro dance ou sans taper dessus elle
a dû revenir à la main l'isu a varié
c'était difficile mais c'est pas ça
c'est le nettoyage enlever tout le
ciment qui était prêt très dur qui
étaient collées dans les angles mais oui
mais c'était dû jeter du métal presse il
avait fondé à la conduite frederic ruffy
les morceaux du site étant dit vous
allez voir le 2e iso dédicaces lizotte
calage bain à l'intérieur on dirait
qu'une souris s'est mise dedans et la
l'intermédiaire que vous avez visité au
passage j'allume a rien rien vous aviez
tout l'outillage nécessaire vous aviez
marqué seulement rien le vent a soufflé
à 6 forme il faisait pas trop les
la nouvelle auberge l'entendait c'était
gênant on en retient pas tout ça mais au
bout d'un moment vous travaillez à
l'intérieur de la nacelle
fonctionnement on se rappelait plus
qu'on était là où exactement se rendent
plus compte
c'est grâce à une maintenance préventive
très minutieuse que l'on peut avoir une
limitation considérable des incidents un
chiffre aussi pour l'année 1965
l'ensemble du réseau ont de moyenne et
ronde l'ong a eu un pourcentage
d'incidents endurées par rapport à la
durée totale des émissions car nous
faisons quelques cinquante cinq mille
heures de diffusion de programmes en
langue grands noms de mayenne en ondes
courtes en modulation de fréquence à
longueur d'année et bien ce pourcentage
d'incidents a été de 0,0 8%
c est à dire que à chiffres extrêmement
faibles
mikati
depuis le dimanche 24 juillet vous
entendez sur france inter sa nouvelle
chanson de route
micros et caméras vous invite à voir et
entendre comment cette chanson fut conçu
et enregistré par claude bolling son
orchestre et les parisiennes
alors si allez olla rouleront la joute
et ma mère avant il
pour écouter la radio
on est les premières devra s'acquitter
nouveau nous n'est jamais certain temps
et protestants
je réponds que c'est bien serré
dans son bain en compagnie d'autres amis
où que l'on se bat qui a trop bien joué
j'avoue
les voisins
azzedine atteint 500 places
son cousin de chez nous
en arrêt ponctuel
inter méditerranée jeu soyez gentils ne
nous appeler plus en ce qui concerne le
catch musicale d'aujourd'hui il est
terminé et vous aurez les résultats
comme d'habitude vers 16h30 dans
quelques instants
vous pourrez de nouveau jouer avec nous
avec le jeu de l'itinéraire 24 heures
sur 24 est la devise de france inter
mais cette année pendant les vacances
sur la méditerranée une nouvelle chaîne
est née interservices méditerranée qui
elle aussi 24 heures sur 24 est aussi à
vis des auditeurs internes et année
c'est une cabine de programmes qui
permet de construire
techniquement ce programme c'est à dire
de faire le mélange des modulations qui
viennent de calvi de hyères de marseille
de nice et de n'envoyer tout ça sur le
réseau des émetteurs 1 termine d'année
c'est un complexe
il fonctionne avec 25 techniciens akale
12 à calvi et 8 aiea
cet ensemble de moyens en personnel et
en matériel
elle nous permet de répondre aux
demandes de la direction générale pour
tous les programmes qu'elle doit
constituer ici et un an l'opération
intermédiaire année si nous restons à
paris il est impossible que nous
ressentions cette atmosphère de détente
que nos auditeurs viennent précisément
cherché sur la côte d'azur
par conséquent les suivants nous sommes
là avec que nous jouons avec eux nous
parlons avec eux nous faisons de la
musique et nous écoutons de la musique
avec eux et nous espérons que
cette communauté leur apporte vraiment
quelque chose en tout cas ce que nous
pouvons dire c'est que nous faisons nous
tous qu'il est en notre pouvoir de faire
pour qu'il soit un peu plus heureux
pendant cette période de les communiquer
la joie de ses 16 ans et qu'est ce que
vous faites dans la vie étudiante bien
et qu'est ce que vous voulez faire plus
tard peut-être ses pages à remonter
d'accueil enfin quelque chose comme ça
pourquoi voulez comme ça ça me plaît
j'aime beaucoup les langues alors à
trois rivières mais alors justement je
voulais mais les chanteurs anglais oui
beaucoup
le chanteur anglais les beatles les
rolling stones liqing je connaissais le
dernier titre des kings c'est rolling
stones the rolling stones the spy à sec
de blague dénoncée par marie laforêt
marie douceur marie colère on l'a passé
hier ou appeler oui voilà vous l'écoutez
tous les jours les cadeaux photos primés
dans général maurice bref bien un père
méditerranée attention attention voici
un communiqué important
on nous signale la disparition de
l'alchimiste broonzy d'or qui est parti
en emportant le secret du bronze vous
êtes tous convoqués demain soir samedi à
21 h 30 place du général de gaulle à
cagnes sur mer afin d'essayer de le
retrouver mort ou vif
au cours d'une grande promenade
radioguidés au bout de laquelle vous
trouverez peut-être broonzy d'or nous le
souhaitons mais sûrement des cadeaux ou
rtf dont un post transistors un
modulation de fréquence ayez soin de
vous munir d'une lampe de poche d'une
carte numéro 84 d'un mouchoir blanc est
naturellement d'un poste à transistor
les auditeurs pourront également jouer
avec nous en téléphonant à 38 23 92
demain soir
chaque fois qu'une déflation depuis
desquels son coup de soleil
ternisien que chaque parent tout l'envié
vous le prouvez d'ailleurs un immédiat à
chaud bonjour les mains peut naître à
menton évidemment on se pense comme
partout il ya beaucoup de soleil
d'ailleurs ici et nous sommes sur le
port vous savez derrière nous il y a le
vieux menton qui est très très beau il
ya la coupole de l'église là au dessus
de moi et puis de l'autre côté c'est un
michel 8 bis quai et dans quelques
minutes
il marche sur le podium installé ici
quarante ans va nous avons été massacrés
d'accord ici à l'audimat
m
et
aie aie aie